[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend eigentlich gibt es in der
politik ja nichts schöneres als einen
zusätzlichen posten besetzen zu können
politische chefs können ihre leute ja
nicht mit gehaltserhöhungen oder
firmenwagen bei laune halten in der
politik sind posten die währung die gibt
es aber nur in sehr überschaubarer zahl
insofern ist es für die führungsriege
der spd eigentlich wunderbar dass sie
als neuerdings stärkste
parlamentsfraktion der posten des
bundestags präsidentin oder präsidentin
zufällt und einen interessenten gibt es
auch schon nur da liegt auch schon das
problem alle verfassungsorgane künftig
nur noch mit männern besetzt
so lange im kanzleramt eine frau saß
fiel das nicht so auf sie überstrahlte
sozusagen den männerüberschuss jetzt
wirds aber augenfällig und bei den
spd-frauen regt sich auch schon protest
das ist aber noch nicht das einzige
problem bei dieser postenvergabe erklärt
andreas künast
die spd kann es als erfolg nummer eins
verbuchen dass die kamera sie nicht
findet an einem geheimen ort speist
heute abend die fraktionsspitze und
sucht einen großen namen für ein großes
amt es wäre erfolg nummer zwei aber er
lässt auf sich warten parteichef walter
borjans hatte fraktionschef mütze nicht
als bundestagspräsident vorgeschlagen
aber viele spd frauen sagen nein kein
mann ich glaube da ist deutschland gut
aufgestellt wenn diese position von
einer frau ausgeführt wird denn gerade
frauen wurden in der letzten
legislaturperiode oft mit bösen
zwischenrufen unter der gürtellinie
angeblich mehr oder weniger auf ihren
platz zurück gedrückt
dass es in 72 jahren bundesrepublik erst
zweimal eine bundestagspräsidentin grad
muss sich zwingend ändern sagen viele
der frauen in der neuen spd
bundestagsfraktion die so selbstbewusst
so groß und so weiblich ist wie lange
nicht auch olaf scholz wäre ganz froh
wenn mütze nicht fraktionschef bliebe
denn scholz hat sich im wahlkampf als
feminist inszeniert nun gilt es wenn
scholz kanzler würde und mütze nicht
bundestagspräsident wäre die ganze
stadtspitze deutschlands wieder komplett
männlich mit bundespräsident steinmeier
und mit den präsidenten von bundesrat
und bundesverfassungsgericht
wir haben eine beteiligung von maximal
34 prozent von frauen im deutschen
bundestag wir haben dann den fünf wochen
spitzen keine frau es ist das anliegen
von frauen wie auch von männern in einer
repräsentativen demokratie von frauen
und von männern geführt zu werden
anstelle von muetze nicht bringen die
spd-frauen die frühere
integrationsbeauftragte aydan özoguz und
fraktionsvorstandsmitglied bärbel bas
ins gespräch sollte es nütze nicht
werden müsste scholz wohl für das
höchste amt deutschlands eine frau
finden und seinen weggefährten
steinmeier zum beispiel durch die grüne
göring eckardt ersetzen das werde
natürlich auch eine möglichkeit aber ich
möchte schon sagen als allererstes würde
uns natürlich die position der
bundestagspräsidentin vorschweben für
den wichtigsten stuhl des bundestags
muss die spd schnell eine lösung finden
die erste sitzung beginnt nächste woche
dienstag um 11 uhr
um die beiden posten die in der cdu noch
zu vergeben sind parteichef und
fraktionschef bewerben sich ja auch nur
noch männer dafür aber gleich eine ganze
riege ihnen gab fdp chef christian
lindner gerade ordentlich einen mit als
er in der bild am sonntag sagte in einer
ampel regierung gewährte die fdp die
anliegen der unions wählerinnen und
wähler im blick behalten nach dem motto
cdu/csu können für ihre anhänger ja
leider nichts mehr tun gott sei dank
gibt es uns und wie dankbar die union
für diesen selbstlosen einsatz ist bei
der fdp hingegen scheint man der jamaika
option nicht länger hinterherzutrauern
lampen berichtet
ohne gegenstimmen beschließt die fdp sie
will weiter gehen in richtung
ampelkoalition parteichef lindner meint
noch sei das ein reines zweckbündnis
aber es könnte ja mehr draus werden denn
das was jetzt an sondierungs papier von
fdp spd und grünen vorliegt enthält sehr
viel mehr liberale politik schon nach
wenigen tagen als das was nach vier
wochen bei den jamaika gesprächen 2017
zur entscheidung anstand an den bislang
bekannten ampel plänen vom ökologischen
umbau bis zur sicheren rente aber klebt
eine frage wie steht es mit der
finanzierung
das ist gar nicht machbar dieser spagat
sehr viel mehr geld ausgeben zu wollen
50 60 milliarden euro mehr pro jahr
gleichzeitig keine mehreinnahmen also
sprich keine zusätzlichen steuern und
man will auch noch die schuldenbremse
einhalten die man schon ohne die
mehrausgaben verfehlen würde dieser
spagat ist gar nicht möglich lindner
kontert man habe auf finanzierbarkeit
geachtet aber nicht alles schon im
sondierungs papier durchdekliniert es
gibt noch keine
[Musik]
haushaltsplanung und auch keine
mittelfristige
finanzplanung
das
sind fragen die jetzt in den nächsten
wochen vorbesprochen werden
mehr konkretes will auch die wirtschaft
ein zusammenschluss von 69
großunternehmen vom stahl bis zum
papierhersteller bekennt sich zu mehr
klimaschutz und mahnt gleichzeitig an es
müssen verlässliche vorgaben her das
reicht einfach nicht mehr dass wir alle
einig sind über das ziel sondern die
wege müssen definiert werden wir als
industrie brauchen einfach ein planungs
rahmen damit für die investitionen die
wir notwendigerweise anstrengen müssen
die dann auch machen können über ein
thema wollen die verhandler eigentlich
nicht reden und reden dann doch das
ganze wochenende darüber wer kriegt
welchen posten christian lindner will
finanzminister werden und sein
vertrauter marco buschmann sekundiert
ich kann mir niemand besseren für diese
aufgabe vorstellen ich habe in den
letzten wochen und monaten gesehen wie
gründlich sich christian lindner auf
diese aufgabe vorbereitet hat
die grünen reagieren genervt der
landespolitiker daniel bahrs twittert
ich kann mir auch niemand besseren als
robert habeck für die aufgabe des
bundesfinanzministers vorstellen er hat
sich nicht erst seit gestern gründlich
auf diese verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
vorbereitet bis bald heute vermeidet
linden der das thema trotzdem steht es
jetzt bei jeder verhandlungsrunde mit im
raum
in dieser pandemie gerade jetzt wo die
kalte jahreszeit wieder losgeht wird ja
immer wieder viel über die schulen
debattiert überwiegend ungeimpfte die
dort auf engem raum zusammen sitzen
geologen warnen davor ausgerechnet im
winter dann auch noch die masken
wegzulassen die elternschaft ist sich da
uneins über
dieses große thema ist ein anderer
bildungsbereich meist aus dem fokus
geraten die studierenden die seite drei
semestern kein normales
universitätsleben mehr kennen
studienanfänger die noch nie in einem
hörsaal gesessen haben
viele fühlten sich einsamen und von
online vorlesungen auch überfordert
jetzt mit beginn des wintersemesters
soll sich das ändern es gibt wieder
präsenz uni wenn auch noch mit vielen
einschränkungen sylvia bleßmann mit
beispielen aus berlin
es ist denn fest etwas ganz besonderes
nach so langer zeit gemeinsam singen vor
publikum auf der bühne stehen kaum
fassbar für die kunststudenten der hanns
eisler in berlin dieses semester mit
einer opernaufführung zu beginnen ein
hochgefühl nach langen dunklen wochen
auch für klarer endlich wieder licht
musizieren spielen zu können
ja einfach auch rückmeldungen zu
bekommen für das was man tut weil wenn
man anderthalb jahre wirklich nur für
sich das ganze macht weiß man irgendwann
auch nicht mehr so ist das ziel führend
unendlich viel disziplin haben sie
sowieso sind gewohnt stundenlang zu üben
aber das reicht nicht so die wichtigste
erfahrung dieser pandemie zeit dass eben
das gemeinschaftlich auf der bühne nicht
ersetzt werden kann und das ist das
worauf wir uns jetzt haben alle meisten
freuen wir haben uns gesteigert in
dieser stillen zeit und wir sind fitter
denn je und jetzt kommen wir alle wieder
zusammen mal darum geht es ja
grünes licht für die rückkehr auf den
campus auch an der tu berlin wie lautet
die aktuelle formel zum semesterstart
drei viertel präsenz und ein viertel
online lehrer anstehen zum
einführungskurs wir keinen nachweis hat
geimpft genesen getestet ist darf nicht
rein in den hörsaal wir achten natürlich
auf unsere masken und wir achten darauf
dass die kurz eingehalten werden also
dass nachweise da sind aufkleber damit
man einen leichten zugang hat oder die
wahl apps damit kommt man jetzt hier
rein und genau das ist das was wir
wieder brauchen lehre mitmensch wie
viele studierende in den hörsaal dürfen
wurde aufwändig berechnet alle müssen
auf abstand achten und müssen sich
online registrieren
die meisten wünschen sich so viel
präsenz wie möglich und dabei ist ihnen
das thema impfen ganz wichtig die uni
macht ja super viel werbung dafür dass
alle geimpft sind ich bin selber auch
geimpft insofern fühle ich mich da
relativ sicher
berlin ist eine international begehrte
studentenstadt an der tu gibt es 20
prozent ausländische studierende ich bin
aus russland gekommen und ich komm ich
bin vollständig dem bauch und zwar mit
biontech allerdings geht das nicht für
alle und bei den aktuell hohen test
kosten bleibt immer ein risiko bei so
viel präsenz an der uni die sorge ist
dass es einen ausbruch gibt aufgrund
eine leere da schlafe ich tatsächlich
ein bisschen unruhig die hoffnung wäre
ist das eben sehr viele wegen der drei
geimpft oder getestet oder genesen sind
so dass das nicht passiert
studierendenvertreter kritisieren dass
lehrende nun auch noch für kontrollen
der sticker mit reggae nachweis
verantwortlich sein sollen vor allem
überwiegt jedoch die freude auf die
chance wieder richtig ins unileben
eintauchen zu können
und mit der allgemeinen corona lage
hierzulande geht es jetzt in den
nachrichten weiterhin
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen hat
sich angesichts der fortschritte bei den
impfungen dafür ausgesprochen die
sogenannte epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite auslaufen zu lassen sie räumt
der bundesregierung bislang
sonderregelungen zum erlass von
verordnungen 1 aktuell gilt diese corona
notlage bis ende november kroner
vorsichtsregeln sollten danach aber
weiter gelten
und so sehen die aktuellen corona zahlen
für deutschland aus innerhalb eines
tages kamen 4056
neuinfektionen hinzu 945 mehr als vor
einer woche auch die inzidenz steigt auf
jetzt
74,4
russland setzt die arbeit seiner
vertretung bei der nato aus auch die
verbindungs und informationsbüros der
nato in moskau würden geschlossen
wahrscheinlich ab dem ersten november
erklärte der russische außenminister
lawrow damit reagiere sein land auf den
ausschluss von acht russischen
vertretern bei der militärallianz in
brüssel die nato hatte ihnen vorgeworfen
für den russischen geheimdienst zu
arbeiten und zu ihnen die akkreditierung
eine gedenkveranstaltung hat dann den
beginn der systematischen
deportation jüdischer menschen durch die
nazis erinnert dabei forderte
bundespräsident steinmeier ein
entschlossenes handeln gegen
antisemitismus vor 80 jahren fuhr der
erste deportation zug von berlin
grunewald aus nach osten gleich 17 wurde
zum öffentlichen mahnmal alleine aus
berlin wurden mehr als 50.000 juden in
arbeits und konzentrationslager
verschleppt
der ehemalige us außenminister und
general colin powell ist an den folgen
einer corona infektion gestorben vier
jahrzehnte hatte er im us militär und
der regierung gedient 2001 wurde paul
unter präsident george hw bush zum
ersten schwarzen außenminister der usa
vor den vereinten nationen präsentierte
paul 2003 vermeintliche beweise für
massenvernichtungswaffen im irak und
sprach sich für einen krieg aus diese
beweise stellten sich später als falsch
heraus paul bezeichnete dies als
schandfleck seiner karriere er wurde 84
jahre alt
was weißrusslands diktator lukaschenko
treiben ist im grunde menschenhandel und
versuchte erpressung erholt flüchtlinge
aus irak oder syrien per flugzeug in
sein land und bringt sie dann an die
grenzen zu geben
das trifft die baltischen länder aber
auch polen das eine lange grenze zu
weißrussland hat die absicht dahinter
ist klar europa unter druck zu setzen
und konflikte auszulösen denn die gibt
es beim flüchtlingsthema ja eh schon
wenn auf einem solchen cenis muss nun
von europäischer seite ebenfalls mit
menschenrechtsverletzungen reagiert
würde
entspreche das nicht geist und regeln
der eu
berichte aus dem polnischen grenzgebiet
sorgen deshalb zunehmend für irritation
natalie stieg aber recht
völlig entkräftet gestrandet im
polnischen chimki im polnischen
fernsehen berichtete der privatsender
tvn24 über das schicksal einer familie
aus syrien über belarus nach polen
gekommen eine hilfsorganisation
die gefunden eine ärztin die unerkannt
bleiben will berichtet eine reporterin
über die situation an der grenze
ich habe schon einiges gesehen aber so
eine humanitäre tragödie noch nicht
solch müde ausgehungerte und unterkühlte
menschen sie sitzen im wald und bitten
um hilfe
was genau direkt an der grenze geschieht
ist unklar den polen hat den
ausnahmezustand verhängt journalisten
und helfer dürfen nicht mehr bis zur
grenze durch nur den migranten die es
über den gesperrten korridor schaffen
kann geholfen werden helfer werfen dem
polnischen grenzschutz vor flüchtlinge
nach belarus zurückzudrängen sogenannte
push back
die menschen wissen oft nicht einmal wo
sie sind manche sind zum beispiel
überzeugt dass sie schon in deutschland
sind oder sie denken dass die
staatsbeamten ihnen helfen werden was
die aber nicht tun
oft nehmen sie die menschen nicht in
einrichtungen auf sondern schieben sie
in einen lkw und fahren sie nach belarus
zurück
gut 400 kilometer ist die polnische
grenze zu belarus lang stacheldraht
liegt seit wochen jetzt will warschau
eine feste grenzanlage bauern hilfe von
der europäischen grenzschutzagentur
frontex lehnt polen ab und will dem
eigenen grenzschutz erlauben vor ort
illegal eingereiste menschen auszuweisen
wir fragen niemanden wie wir unsere
ostgrenze schützen sollen die
gleichzeitig die ostgrenze der eu ist
der druck auf die polnische grenze thema
auch beim eu außenministertreffen heute
in polen man gut beraten wäre die
frontex wirklich eine aufgabe zu geben
ich verstehe dass polen äußerst
schwierigen situation ist genau wie wir
klauen aber man muss das
tausende geflohene versuchen seit dem
sommer von belarus aus die grenze zu
überwinden ihr ziel meist deutschland
von lukaschenko regime gezielt aus
nahost und afghanistan eingeflogen und
weiter richtung westen geschleust
der chef eines staatlichen schleuserring
und wir sind nicht länger bereit
zuzusehen dass es auch unternehmen
gipfel fluggesellschaften die damit auch
noch geld verdienen eine gruppe aus irak
regelmäßig kommen neue menschen manche
herren tage ja wochen im wald aus
es ist ein kampf gegen die zeit um nicht
bald hier über leichen zu stolpern was
bald kommt weil der winter
die gruppe aus irak wird schließlich vom
polnischen grenzschutz mitgenommen der
informiert später ein teil von ihnen
wurde wieder zur grenze gebracht soll
zurück nach belarus
was letztendlich die fluchtursachen
bekämpft werden müssten ist natürlich
eine binsenweisheit und lagern auch die
schwierigste herausforderung unter der
weste in afghanistan beispielsweise ja
gerade erst gescheitert ist aus dem
reich der taliban werden jetzt noch mehr
menschen versuchen zu fliehen bis in die
eu ist es allerdings ein langer und
teurer weg viel näher liegen andere
staaten an deren entwicklung die
europäer größtes interesse haben müssen
von nordafrika von den maghreb staaten
trennt die eu ja nur ein vergleichsweise
schmaler streifen wasser beispiel
tunesien dass dort jetzt eine frau zur
regierungschefin ernannt wurde mag
manchen überraschen
doch das besagt nicht viel die macht im
land hatte ein anderer und die große
frage ist wohin er es führt auch darüber
berieten heute die eu außenminister an
haaren nimmt uns mit nach tunesien
wohin steuert tunesien die journalistin
hatte grammer ag blickt mit sorge auf
die machtübernahme des präsidenten denn
kaiser jetzt spaltet die gesellschaft
die einen sehen ihn als retter in der
wirtschaftskrise die anderen als gefahr
für die junge demokratie
seit der revolution vor gut zehn jahren
hat es viele krisen gegeben das stimmt
aber immerhin haben wir damals die
diktatur überwunden
zwar zeigt sich der präsident
fortschrittlich indem er eine
premierministerin einsetzt doch nabu
denn hat kaum eigene befugnisse es gibt
keine parlamentarische kontrolle der
notstand der sayed erlaubt per dekret zu
regieren gilt weiterhin kritik aus dem
ausland begegnet er mit deutlichen
worten
tunesien ist ein freier und unabhängiger
staat niemand hat sich in unsere
angelegenheiten einzumischen wie sie
wissen haben sich unsere politischen
gegner ein vertreter im ausland gewandt
und sie gebeten unsere interessen
anzugreifen
am 25 juli hatte der präsident parlament
und regierung entlassen seitdem regiert
er nahezu im alleingang und doch
unterstützen viele tunesier seinen kurs
seine beliebtheit gegründet allein auf
dem scheitern der vorherigen regierungen
aber er hat kein eigenes projekt wir
haben noch nichts von seinem politischen
programm gehört
so ist es die verzweiflung vor allem im
vom armut geprägten landesinneren die
den nährboden für sei jetzt zuspruch
bildet tunesien galt lange als vorbild
des arabischen frühlings doch bis heute
hat der demokratische wandel keine
stabilität gebracht stattdessen
politische machtspiele und korruption
das hoch verschuldete land steht kurz
vor dem bankrott
das volk muss dafür zahlen die preise
sind gestiegen für alles und die löhne
reichen nicht
ich erwarte nur gutes vom präsidenten er
ist streng nicht korrupt man hat noch
nichts schlechtes von ihm gehört
die die ihm nicht vertrauen wollen nur
weg sowie haltung das geld das sie hier
verdient spart sie für einen platz in
einem der schlepper boote sie hofft auf
ein besseres leben in europa
dort werden deine rechte respektiert
nicht so wie hier in tunesien
das wird auch mit der neuen regierung
nicht besser die höheren seit jahren
dass sich etwas ändern wird aber ich
glaube nicht mehr daran
ramadi will nicht aufgeben sie will die
demokratie verteidigen auch wenn sie
befürchtet dass sie probleme bekommen
könnte
eines will seit der machtübernahme am 25
juli hat man angefangen uns wegen
anderer meinungen zu verfolgen einige
abgeordnete carmen vors militärgericht
kaum einer kann derzeit abschätzen wie
es in dem krisengeschüttelten land
weitergeht doch die ungeduld wächst bei
allen tunesien
und jetzt nochmal heinsberg nachrichten
aus der wirtschaft
facebook will in den kommenden fünf
jahren in der europäischen union 10.000
neue hochqualifizierte arbeitsplätze
schaffen das haben zwei facebook
topmanager in einem blogeintrag
angekündigt sind meine songs hat
facebook hier vor also mit meter worlds
wie facebooks neuestes projekt
tatsächlich heißt soll die realwelt mit
der virtuellen verschmelzen so soll nun
eine neue ebene des internets entstehen
das freut die facebook aktionäre die
papiere sind zeitweise mehr als drei
prozent im plus aber nicht an der
frankfurter sondern an der new yorker
börse nasdaq hier in europa will
facebook für sein projekt 10.000 neue
stellen innerhalb der nächsten fünf
jahre schaffen der zugang zur virtuellen
welt meter wirst soll dann über
smartphones pcs oder spezielle brillen
erfolgen von europa verspricht sich
facebook nach eigenen angaben einen
großen verbrauchermarkt
erstklassige universitäten sowie
hochklassige arbeitskräfte womöglich ein
politischer schachzug wir sollten als
europäer uns erst mal zurückhalten und
abwarten was wirklich von facebook
geboten wird und facebook dazu anhalten
dass sie unsere gesetze einhalten
insbesondere die datenschutzgesetze aber
auch die steuern in deutschland zahlen
datenschutz und steuerzahlungen nicht
die einzigen themen bei denen facebook
immer wieder in der kritik steht der
oktober bescherte facebook zusätzlich
negativ schlagzeilen sei es ein
stundenlanger ausfall seiner social
media plattformen
oder die vorwürfe die facebook tochter
instagram gefährde die psychische
gesundheit junger nutzer mit metros und
dem investment in europa startet
facebook nun eine art charmeoffensive
sina mainitz vielen dank gerne der
medienkonzern axel springer hat bild
chefredakteur julian reichelt mit
sofortiger wirkung von seinen aufgaben
entbunden das teilte das unternehmen
heute mit der konzern wirft reichelt vor
auch nach abschluss eines compliance
verfahrens im frühjahr 2021 privates und
berufliches nicht klar getrennt und dem
vorstand darüber die unwahrheit gesagt
zu haben neuer vorsitzender der bild
chefredaktion wird johannes boje derzeit
chefredakteur welt am sonntag
der dieselpreis ist an tankstellen in
deutschland auf rekordhöhe gestiegen im
vergangenen monat lag der liter bei rund
1 eur 41 gestern musste dann im schnitt
sogar ein eur 55 gezahlt werden in
dieser region war der preis zuletzt 2012
als ein preistreiber beim sprit gilt vor
allem der nach dem krone einbruch des
vergangenen jahres gestiegene ölpreis
in der antiken stätte von olympia in
griechenland wurde das feuer für die
olympischen winterspiele in peking
entfacht nur wenige geladene gäste haben
an der zeremonie teilgenommen einen
traditionellen fackellauf mit vielen
zuschauern das aufgrund der korona
pandemie nicht geben bei der zeremonie
haben demonstranten gegen das
gastgeberland china protestiert und vor
allem die menschenrechtslage in tibet
angeprangert
gelesen wurde in der pandemie zwar viel
aber für buchhandel autoren und verlage
war es trotzdem eine harte zeit so viele
veranstaltungen die aus vielen lesungen
die nicht stattfand autoren und
autorinnen die sich nicht präsentieren
konnten und während der
ladenschließungen fiel natürlich auch
der spontane buchkauf aus der bücher
liebt kennt das ja man kommt immer mit
mehr unterm arm raus als man eigentlich
kaufen wollt bitte aber auch dass das
größte branchenereignis die frankfurter
buchmesse im letzten jahr abgesagt wurde
es gab sie virtuell aber das ist ein
bisschen so als würde man virtuell eine
kneipe besuchen die entscheidenden
gespräche das netzwerken das braucht
einfach das direkte miteinander in
diesem jahr kann das nun alles wieder
real stattfinden einschließlich
feierliche verleihung des deutschen
buchpreises aus frankfurt enden klinge
die gewinnerin des deutschen buchpreises
bringt um worte
[Applaus]
sehr überwältigt sprachlos und
freue mich riesig aber sie fasst sich
schnell und nutzt die bühne auch für ein
statement zum thema geschlechtergerechte
sprache
aber sobald ich anfangen darüber
nachzudenken
übertönt mich gezerre und gezielter und
ich lande mitten in einem furchtbaren
krieg dem krieg der heute verbissen und
benennungen und bezeichnung geführt wird
die sprache ist der 47 jährigen autorin
aus potsdam besonders wichtig und die
sprache in ihrem roman blaue frau lobt
auch die jury die sie für das eigentlich
unaussprechliche gefunden habe es ist
die geschichte über eine vergewaltigung
einfühlsam und fesselnd erzählt antje
rávic strubel von adina einer jungen
frau aus tschechien die es in die ferne
zieht sie hat sich in helsinki in einen
plattenbau zurückgezogen unsichtbar
gemacht wie es im buch heißt diener lebt
mit einem trauma ein kulturpolitiker hat
sie als praktikantin in deutschland
vergewaltigt die machtgefälle zwischen
ost und westeuropa und zwischen mann und
frau die will antje rávic strubel
benennen ich fing an zu recherchieren
und stellte fest dass das ein phänomen
ist dass offensichtlich
uns viel zu normal betrachtet wird also
unsere gesellschaft hat einfach viel zu
viel oder ist einfach durchsetzt mit
sexueller gewalt gegen frauen und das
fand ich furchtbar
am wasser taucht immer wieder eine
rätselhafte blaue frau auf die
titelfigur und scheint geschehenes
zusammenzufassen die blaue frau tauchte
einfach auf wurde immer lebendiger in
meinem kopf und ich habe mit ihr
gespräche geführt und immer wenn sie da
war fühlte ich mich irgendwie so
aufgehoben und geborgen und war in der
lage diesen diesen roman zu schreiben
für die jury ist das buch von antje
rávic strubel unter anderem deshalb
preiswürdig weil es auch um die macht
der literatur gehe antje rávic strubel
ist eine geschichten können um es mit
einem wort aus ihrem eigenen roman
auszudrücken cnc wahrlich finstere
geschichte die geschichte einer
vergewaltigung
gleichzeitig aber auch die geschichte
einer
ermächtigung der jungen frau die eine
traumatische erfahrung gemacht hat und
unter anderem auch mit hilfe der
literatur der kraft der literatur
versucht ins leben zurückzukehren die
konkurrenz war wieder stark mitunter den
letzten sechs unter anderem der
bestseller autor christian kracht die
blaue frau wurde ausgezeichnet
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es mit dem montagskino
weiter und dann gibt es uns heute schon
mal update und 23.45 mit gundula gause
das waren auf wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend mit dem ruhigen herbstwetter
geht es jetzt zu ende denn das hoch fiel
linie zieht weiter richtung schwarzes
meer jetzt übernimmt ein sturmtief
hendrik heißt das aber bevor es bei uns
so richtig windig wird wird erst mal
sehr mild so steigen die temperaturen
zum beispiel in zwickau und chemnitz
aber auch in freiburg auf bis zu 23 grad
heute nacht kommt erst mal regen im
westen an der erreicht den ost nicht in
bayern bildet sich auch mal nebel die
temperaturen in dieser nacht sinken auf
werte zwischen 13 grad am niederrhein
und 4 grad hier in oberbayern und morgen
ist es wirklich ungewöhnlich mild für
mitte oktober uns erwarten häufig werte
zwischen 16 und 20 grad und nur hier
zwischen dem nordhessischen bergland und
den bayerischen wald sowie im nordosten
bleibt es bei 12 bis 15 grad etwas
kühler der regen der nach sieht weiter
nach osten wird über den äußersten osten
wohl nicht erreichen und am nachmittag
lockern die wolken hier im südwesten
schon wieder auf bei südwestwind und
dann kommt der sturm herab schon am
mittwoch stürmt es an den küsten von
nord- und osthessen kräftige schauer und
gewitter unterwegs davor aber wird es
richtig war 23 grad in sachsen oder auch
am oberrhein und danach wird es noch
wendiger es zieht dieses strom fällt
hier etwa vom saarland weiter nach
nordosten und da liegen die temperaturen
am donnerstag noch bei zwölf bis
achtzehn am freitag aber nur noch bei
sechs bis zwölf grad guten abend